your boy Mr Beast did it again
uh cure blindness this guy is
unbelievable he really is something else
bro and it it exposes what a piece of
[__] I am because I turn on a video like
damn probably that blind like I was
trying to find ways to like hate on two
minutes in the video
are they only fixing one high because
they was only taking off one patch and I
was like oh my God he could have fixed
500 people both eyes well one thousand
one he thought he was copping a deal and
he was like Jimmy really you you Jimmy
yeah and then the guy takes off both
eyes he's like all right okay yeah it
was it was fine he actually did legit do
it yeah yeah
um and then went around the world and
did it too that's cool unbelievable
probably in India though I bet that was
you [__]
Indonesia
I hate to say this [__] what is he
saying disrespect son it's not the same
[__] do you want to cure them in India
because then they won't think mud is a
[__] again
you guys know you're [__] cheap or
whatever in your family yes no no we
don't [__] our family if there's no no
yeah you don't [__] your family Sheep No
the Sheep we [__] but not our family you
either [__] sheep or your family no you
[__] sheep yeah we [__] sheep you're
adding your family there your family
[__] sheep that's what I'm saying I'm
not agreeing yeah I agree so what we're
saying
you [__] mud yeah mud is way better
sheep's got a wagon on them
yeah but this [__] so it's gay too mud
is genderless oh that's not good mud is
genderless when you take a dick out of
mud
yeah exactly bro yeah think about that
yeah but you know I mean it's better to
act like than to do it
[Music]
there's like a chat GPT argument like I
think he's like what do I say now
what would you rather your people [__]
like a living sheep with like a heart
and a soul or mud mud you would bro much
softer you would bro much softer monsoon
season this [__] is wet I mean it's that
wet yo sheep get wet
do they yeah no because it's all that
moisture getting dried up in the cotton
there's bigger things happening in the
world dude yeah Mr B's cured a thousand
people of blindness yeah it's a big deal
and so far you've only cured one I feel
like we needed two I was hating bro I'm
not gonna lie we had to do more
philanthropy why is that your initial
response when you see someone do someone
nice being like that
you're the Twitter haters he's getting a
bunch of hate on Twitter right now wait
why because people are like trying to be
God yeah two things oh you're doing it
for clout anybody trying to be a good
person on Twitter they're like I don't
trust it and then other people like
Hassan did a reaction on his stream and
he was like it's my initial reaction he
was like it's so [__] up that like 50
of blindness in the world can be cured
as like a 10 minute surgery it's like
three grand and governments can't fix
this is it governments or doctors can't
do it a little bit like why why does he
got to pay the doctors why are the
doctors like maybe I'll donate a little
of my time right like if you're a doctor
and you could do the surgery just go to
work early cure one blind do the day I
feel like to be a nice thing to do no
they say laughter is the best medicine
why don't you do some free shows I do
that's the actual point bro
hi everybody at home how you doing a
million people watching did y'all pay
for this cut the break right now I know
right they're not paying it sounds a
Bluetooth man I really appreciate y'all
make sure you buy for that yeah anyway
point is
Bluetooth is a great product
no no the point is what he did was
absolutely great and it was stupid for
even me to like be so critical or maybe
so cynical but what he's doing is
amazing and even if you're doing it to
get views if you're doing something
great just [__] do it yeah who cares
it is weird when you like videotape
yourself like giving a homeless person
money like those tick tocks are a little
bit weird but when you up the stakes to
medical procedures and a thousand people
the other difference I think with this
stuff and like giving a random guy a
thousand bucks is like your the amount
that you volunteer for it like he put an
ad being like hey if you're blind show
up like people are opting in to be a
part of the experience
this guy's desperate he's like hey
here's money but the only way you're
gonna get it is if you let me post this
video like it's a great seems like
extortionary whereas what he's doing
here is like hey come come if you have
problems we'll we'll help you that's a
great point and we see from his track
record that he puts that money back into
doing stuff like this yeah so it's like
he has to monetize this video so that
way he can continue making money so he
can continue doing good deeds yeah oh
exactly yeah it's like you want him to
make money because he just keeps on
helping people he's the one person that
you want to make as much money as
possible yes the more money Mr beaks
Beast makes the more people will get
helped yeah he's the non-profit you
trust yeah I mean most non-profit like
the NFL is a non-profit organization
it's like you're actively killing people
but this guy non-profit every video I
get I'm gonna do something good with it
he and just cure a thousand people with
blindness he gave one guy fifty thousand
dollar scholarships bought a guy a Tesla
gave another guy ten thousand donated a
hundred thousand to the guy who is doing
the surgery I mean yeah the doctor's
doing the surgeries
um which is wild he should have been
witnessing that and be like you know
what this feels good I'll do that for
free I think they do it for free I think
they probably bake in their year to do
it yeah they do yeah good work
missionary good work I better [__] do
that [__] I mean but now here's the
thing if you're like the local church if
you're like the local mosque if you're
the local temple are you seeing this
done by this YouTuber and are you going
[__] we need to step it up the [__] are
we doing no you should but you're not no
or just a pure acquisition
Jimmy come work for us all right we'll
make you the pope yeah that's a good
idea I don't know why Jews you guys
could do that make him like the top
Rabbi or something and then all of a
sudden it's just absorbed to be like hey
now you're Jewish
talk to your boys
[Music]
well they got like people in charge of
communities but no not like you guys
something I think Bobby Spielberg that's
something that's awesome
[Music]
I don't know that's not you this is the
so this is
the lvr anger lvmh no Bernardo no yeah
yeah yeah not Jewish oh he's not no no
he's taste yeah like he actually
understands all this time heads of his
companies are juice say again the heads
of his company they lost the bottom line
exactly
you know what I mean like the bottom
juice you know yeah
okay so if he doesn't get absorbed into
a religion I'm curious when you're
watching this like if you were what is a
guy's name from Houston Joel Osteen yeah
like is there a little part of him
that is envious like is he competitive
in the way that like uh Comics are
competitive or is he competitive in the
way that like athletes are competitive
you know it's like oh [__] uh when Kobe
saw Shaq get his fourth ring he's like
no I need to make sure I get more I'm
sure they're doing some philanthropy
like you'd like to hope these religious
organizations are doing something to
help the community but they just don't
necessarily have the greatest video and
algorithm teams to create the best
content I also think maybe streaming
their [__] every single Sunday on TV
yeah like so what you're doing I don't
know what they're doing but I'm saying
like I imagine some of them are
justifying where they're like oh yeah we
do have this charity we clothed this
many people we feed this many people so
yeah we're doing our parts I know they
were turning away people when it was
like a big ass storm I know they were
doing that well maybe Jimmy turn away
someone the 1001 person that was blind
like hey let me in he was like no videos
a thousand why are you [__] on Jimmy
I know that's crazy it'll be a thousand
one why didn't you do a thousand and one
why don't you ask him that why don't you
call him Jimmy right now it's in Joel do
one
that's a good point you know how they
spent like 80 percent of uh commercial
spends are medical companies and
pharmacies why you gotta think of the
worst possible system okay when the 1000
one person no it is funny to think that
he goes up to the [__] office in
Indonesia and they just got to be like
nah Famers so much he probably held more
than a thousand people but it's so funny
to think that one guy showed up like
hello is anyone here and he's like sorry
dude well why don't they lie to him be
like this isn't the office for yeah this
is Wendy's
no I think it's here you would think
that wouldn't you yeah if you couldn't
see yeah [__] blind idiot yeah
Indonesian guy that can't see anything
yeah [__] idiot guy yeah why don't
you go build some ancient structures in
the jungle that are awesome that no one
knows how to build true truth yeah yeah
true okay
um yo shout out to [__] Jimmy man
okay how are we gonna help who do we
want to help
um y'all are selfish bro no no we could
think we could think of someone that
could deserve it
blindness are we gonna do blindness we
don't want to do we don't want to be
happy I love the I love the the idea of
like
it's not like a generic like the
environment like I like the idea of like
specifically targeting one thing also I
don't care about the ugly women don't
care about the yo we could do bbos you
want to do ugly women well we already
helping by Mark stealing all their
clothing
they can't think you're not going to go
out in public if they can't wear that
okay
so they're safer they're not gonna get
any change and also these fat girls are
so [__] upset about me because that
one Rogan episode say again I didn't say
fat I said ugly okay well what are we
gonna do with ugly women we could do a
thousand BBs for plastic surgery or bbos
but I should put them all in a boat like
refugees and just push them to another
country no see that's that's the
opposite yeah that's it didn't work out
great it's moving that's just moving if
I lose weight on the boat trip at least
you could just take them halfway and
bring them I'll try to help them okay
okay okay okay so ugly women that's one
dudes no no they got to step it up get
them some some talks let's just match
ugly women with alcoholics because
they're not gonna know how ugly the girl
is anyway and then everybody gets laid
what's an actual group of struggling
people now for real like what what can
you do on this show we support men so
why don't we give surgeries to all the
trans men that want dicks Dick's for
everyone that's kind of Fire
that way we can turn the tires we can
get more dudes we want to help the boys
more than anything obviously I think
that would really help
any objections I'm good on all that man
someone throw it on a thousand dicks
around the world Indonesia you can put
it anywhere on your body 500 cut off 500
so we held both genders sure we can do
that also both transgenders you can put
a thousand dicks anywhere you want one I
think they try to make that trade I was
just thinking that like make a site that
connects to people that want to get rid
of their dicks on the one yeah new dick
yeah oh you're gonna swap them well yeah
I mean what are you going to do with all
that flesh like you no longer need that
flesh it's a good point transfer.com
that's a great idea that now there's a
business idea this is you know
capitalism kicking in right do this what
do we want to help bro do they have to
like put dicks in like the ice bucket
and like get it on a helicopter yeah
they dump it on their head to raise
awareness 100 wow yeah and you don't
know what dick you're gonna get and some
of you you know you might identify as a
man but not a [__] Taiwanese one you
know what I mean like there's certain
dicks that are going to be maybe not
what you imagine you would have if you
were if you were a dude you know so
there's one show on Netflix right now
this is a side that's changing Asian
stereotypes around the world physical
100 have you heard of this no no you've
always watch them this show is
unbelievable it's literally squid game
in real life they got a bunch of Koreans
in a room and they make them do physical
challenges until there's one left and he
wants a bunch of money whoa awesome and
you watch and you're like I didn't know
Koreans could get that big American
Ninja Warrior it's similar it's similar
but it's only Koreans and they're all
jacked and you watch it and you're like
oh no there's some big dick Koreans out
here wait oh you actually see penises no
but you can imagine I was imagining oh
but you can get a sense though yeah
these are big dicks these unfortunately
for South Koreans they are known for
having the smallest penises on the
planet
Oh I thought you say of Koreans no no on
the planet North korean's probably smart
well we haven't measured them I don't
know I imagine I mean at least yeah it's
not going to be it's not going to be as
nourished it won't be worthy for sure
yeah this show is changing is changing
everything over there it's really
amazing you should watch it I'd highly
recommend it but anyway what's crazy
that we still can't find a group of
people what about animals we can help
animals I don't want to help what about
specific animals like no don't care
about even noodles there's hundreds of
golden doodles he wants a quick result
like can we help with the 10 minute
surgery like laser hair removal for
someone really fat bro there's golden
what'd you say laser hair removal for
someone that's really fat it's more
expensive I didn't know how I connected
that because I was about to go I'm
trying to get a hair transplant
hair transplant you should give bald
guys their [__] hair yeah that's good
that's a great idea
don't be selfish selfish
I promise I won't pay for no because
you're gonna get a referral give me a
thousand people to get one free and
you're gonna [__] watch that [__] it
takes too long and then if they don't
upkeep then it doesn't stay people will
do the work that's on them it's true Mr
Beast pick the perfect thing you walk in
there you're seeing again can we do it
for the deaf what does that mean can we
give uh sound to the deaf hearing to the
deaf is that possible Cochlear implants
Cochlear implants we do Cochlear
implants how much is that surgery at all
if it's quite expensive and also I think
it's sort of hard yeah but how much is
the vision one that's probably something
yeah
anyone that's a doctor for Cochlear oh
we could do Cochlear implants and then
every implant gets this podcast directly
on it and we get to choose what they
listen to and they only listen to our
show smart that's a good idea so then
it's bumping numbers but also the
sponsor for this audible audible.com
what's up exactly and then we can
control their implants at any time we
don't even yeah just get shell some
credits love audible
um that's a good idea I like that yeah
definitely uh overestimated the amount
of books I was going to be reading
you signed me up for some extra [__] I
ain't even need then give me no more
credits then I signed up for the whole
year thinking I was just gonna be
blasting through books and nope
nope their Cochlear implants start to
stop working they want nothing to do
with it if it's not ancient civilization
I want to read about it I don't want to
know anything what counts as ancient how
old
younger drives okay well it's about 12
500 years yeah between 10 and 12 000
years ago younger drives end of the ice
age is that a dragon is that again is it
a dragon no it's not a dragon
it's one of the most
crazy things ever happened to me
Humanity hey instrumental downpours I
mean it was absolutely cataclysmic
yeah it was absolutely cataclysmic you
see album you dress like me you can be
watching [__] like me too
you're gonna say it you're gonna say
this Atlanta tomorrow's patreon episode
is so interesting two two months two
months
[Music]
yeah it happens it's a real thing yeah
let's cure the artist right yeah now you
hid behind the racial thing we can't be
like yeah
what if what makes people feel really
good
um opiates okay what if we start a
pharmaceutical company and then we're
able to prescribe people opiates
real things why are you so Catholic all
the time yeah no we need that
Catholicism
this is literally a good idea Maniac
have you ever done opiate have you ever
done oxygen or something how good did
you feel what if you could make everyone
feel that good all the time I couldn't
see anything going wrong with that
situation I can't see a single thing
potentially that's the front runner
that's the front runner what's the
average price of breast implants oh
Jesus out where are they you wouldn't
put a bunch of flagrant tits
like
and then they can wear the Heavies merch
and then be like yo those flagrant tits
and have his merch yeah that's a decent
idea you call it the it's like the
Heavies Foundation
that's fire
it's great and then years later one of
the tits just explodes yo come on that's
on you though nuclear implants that's
what we should do shut up
[__] is whack it's not gonna get
emotional
yes it will no it won't seen those
videos because they don't know how to
talk they got videos get out of their
surgery still dude
right because they don't know how to
pronounce [__] just yet it's going to
take a little bit why are you so angry
just made a joke
we could do a voiceover we could just do
a voiceover of it yeah so when they come
out